how do you know how to be a good dad you
actually have to respect your children
as though they have cognizable wishes
which sometimes can be hard because kids
are not famous for being smart they're
small they're children they're not
supposed to be adults but you have to
actually treat them with a certain level
of respect and you have to treat them as
though their desires are meaningful you
also have to say no and you have to set
rules and you have to be willing to
stick by those rules because it's your
job to craft this person into a person
who's capable of being a good dad of his
own Boys in particular really really
need father figures to model what it
looks like to be a good man and when you
remove that father figure that is not
fillable by a woman it's just not
there's no such thing as woman who can
be a father it's not it's not the same
that's not say a woman can't be an
unbelievable mother and fill gaps that
exist in different ways but she's not
going to be an ad you know what it's
like to be a bad dad but you can start
with that you know what it's like to be
a bad dad and by contrast that does
leave a fairly wide area to be mediocre
to good dad